Then we've got the widget component.
We've talked about creating these elements, how to display them on screen,
but a relatively common, more modern setup to do is maybe we want these widgets to exist within world geometry
or to respond to world space coordinates in some way, and that's where the widget component comes in.
The widget component manifests 3D UI elements created through EMG in the world.
The widget component itself is a 3D instance of the widget blueprint that you can interact with,
and it offers a huge range of properties that we can leverage as developers,
but some of the key properties we should be concerned about are the space.
As the name implies, this is a component.
It's a component you can put on actors.
Those actors can be in the world, obviously.
So then the space becomes quite important
because this is the coordinate space in which this widget is rendered.
So this can either be world or screen.
World space means that the component's position, rotation, scale all get taken into account,
and this widget is literally rendered as no different from a plane in your world, but with the widget on it.
So it has perspective, it has the rotation matters, all of these things.
Screen space is really the only property that matters about this component is its position.
Its rotation doesn't matter, its scale doesn't matter,
but its position is essentially projected onto your screen
and is used for where this widget should be displayed on your screen.
If you think about something like objective markers in other games,
typically those things don't often tend to get a huge amount bigger,
larger on your screen as you get closer to them.
They don't get smaller as you get further away.
They can stay the same size and they just indicate to you this thing could be two miles away,
but they indicate to you in relation to your screen now, where would this objective be.
That's the kind of use case for something like a screen space widget.
The widget class obviously specifies what kind of widget is this component actually displaying.
So that's a widget that we've probably created ourselves,
inherited from the user widget class.
The draw size, which is essentially the size of the quad that we're going to draw this widget onto.
Whether or not the widget is focusable.
So this determines whether or not the virtual window that gets created for this widget is focusable
and should this take focus from the user.
And then the pivot, which is a little bit like our alignment that we've talked about with the canvas panel,
which is basically the ability to have where should the widget,
how should the widget position itself in relation to the component.
So if our pivot is 0.5, 0.5,
the center of our widget is going to be aligned over the components position.
If our pivot is 0.51,
then the center bottom of the component is going to be where the widget is going to be where the component actually is.
So where the pivot of the widget in relation to the component itself.